four years ago here at Ted I announced
planets mission one to launch a fleet of
satellites that would image the entire
Earth every day and to democratize
access to it the problem we were trying
to solve was simple
satellite imagery you find online is old
typically years old yet human activity
was happening on days and weeks and
months and you can't fix what you can't
see we wanted to give people the tools
to see that change and take action the
beautiful Blue Marble image taken by the
Apollo 17 astronauts in 1972 had helped
humanity become aware that we're on a
fragile planet and we wanted to take it
to the next level to give people the
tools to take action to take care of it
well after a mini Apollo project of our
own launching the largest fleet of
satellites in human history we've
reached our target today planet images
the entire Earth every single day
mission accomplished thank you
it's taken 21 rocket launches this
animation makes it look really simple it
was not and we now have over 200
satellites in orbit down making their
data 231 ground stations we built around
the planet and totally we get 1.5
million
29 megapixel images of the earth down
each day and on any one location on the
Earth's surface we now have on average
more than 500 images a deep stack of
data documenting immense change and lots
of people are using this imagery
agricultural companies are using it to
improve farmers crop yields consumer
mapping companies are using it to
improve the the maps you find online
governments are using it for border
security or helping with disaster
response after floods and fires and
earthquakes and lots of NGOs are using
it so for tracking and stopping
deforestation they are helping to find
the refugees fleeing Miami or to track
all the activities in the ongoing crisis
in Syria
holding all sides accountable and today
I'm pleased to announce Planet stories
anyone can go online to planner calm Oh
open an account and see all of our
imagery online Yuka is a bit like Google
Earth except it's up-to-date imagery and
you can see back through time you can
compare any two days and see the
dramatic changes that happen around our
planet or you can create a time lapse
through the 500 images that we have and
see that change dramatically over time
and you can share these over social
media it's pretty cool thank you we
initially created this tool for news
journalists who wanted to get unbiased
information about world events but now
we've create open it up for anyone to
use for nonprofit or personal uses and
we hope people it will give people the
tools to find and see the changes on the
planet and take action okay so humanity
now has this database of information
about the planet changing over time
what's our next mission what's merton
mission - in short it's space plus AI
what we're doing with artificial
intelligence is finding the objects in
all the all the subtle images the same
AI tools that have used to find cats in
videos online can also be used to find
information on our pictures so imagine
if you can say this is a ship this is a
tree this is a car this is a road this
is a building this is a truck and if you
could do that for all of the millions of
images coming down per day then you
basically create a database of all the
sizeable objects on the planet every day
and that database is searchable so
that's exactly what we're doing here's a
prototype working on an API this is
Beijing so imagine if we wanted to count
the planes in the airport we select the
airport and it finds the planes in
today's image and finds the planes in
the whole stack of images before it and
then outputs this graph of all the
planes in the Beijing Airport over time
of course you could do this for all the
airports around the world and let's look
here in the Port of Vancouver so they
would do the same but this time we'll
look for vessels so
we zoom in on Vancouver we select the
area and we search for ships and it
outputs the way all the ships are now
imagine how useful this would be to have
people in Coast Guard's who are trying
to track and stop illegal fishing see
illegal fishing vessels transmitted at
their locations using AAS beacons but we
frequently find ships that are not doing
that the pictures don't lie
and so Coast Guard's could use that can
go and find those illegal fishing
vessels and zoom will add not just ships
and planes but all the other objects and
we can output data feeds of those
locations of all these objects over time
that could be integrated into different
peoples workflows in time we could get
more sophisticated browsers that people
pull in from different sources but
ultimately I can imagine us abstracting
out the imagery entirely and just having
a queryable interface to the earth
imagine if we could just ask hey how
many houses are there Pakistan give me a
plot of that versus time how many trees
are there in the Amazon and can you tell
me the locations of the trees that have
been felled between this week and last
week when they'll be great well that's
what we're trying to go towards and we
call it queryable Earth so planets
mission one was to image the whole
planet every day and make it accessible
Matt's mission too is to index all the
objects on the planet over time and make
it queryable let me leave you with an
analogy google index what's on the
internet and made it searchable
well we're indexing what's on the earth
and making it searchable thank you very
much
[Applause]
[Music]